I imagine you would it taste like what
you need based on the tea egg theory you
would taste like the things that you're
surrounded by so you actually just
tastes like me that is probably the most
gross thought I've ever been subjected
to this is an episode I never would have
imagined we would do yeah me neither but
I'm thrilled that we're doing it today
we're having three eggs at three
drastically different price points to
find out which egg this is the most part
of it has given price point what do you
love about eggs
I love how like when you cook them and
you mess up you still have to puke and
eat like you can try making an omelet
but if you mess up you just got
scrambled eggs things are also kind of
cute but some eyes on egg you got toka
peas - what you know what Togepi is no
took a pre excuse me I'm cool
I typically hate your puns but I feel
like today yeah today's your day and I'm
letting you have it so you're saying to
Andres Oh looks like we're all joining
in on the fun today
exactly
hi I'm David Wong I'm the chef and also
the co-owner of loud house tray food we
are serving hi one is inspired Street
food today I gonna show you guys how we
make the oolong tea flavor X sea flavor
eggs spin around for centuries for a
peasant people they can use a little bit
of the tea leaves marinade into the eggs
so they can get a taste of the premium
team so it's kind of more about making a
little bit of ingredients go a longer
way exactly the first step is for you
the eggs for 10 to 12 minutes and then
you have to ice that right away so it
doesn't overcook here on the surface for
a couple of kinds but lightly then you
have the pin chip because we want to get
this pipe where a pattern on the surface
of the eggs while the eggs cooling down
then we do the marinade we use 12
different spices cinnamon sticks
star anise search 1 peppercorns then we
dump the eggs into the juice and the
lettuce set for 12 hours
what can you tell me about the little
mascot guy he's a hoodie monster this
little thing loves to eat one day he
even like he got so hungry a part of
himself if you consider yourself well
funny that you call yourself a long time
sometimes I feel like I could just take
[Music]
you got this dope ginger line made we do
yeah that's chia seeds chia seeds I'd be
careful here because they're filled to
the brim
[Music]
it's kind of like I spilled some of my
ginger ale in my lemonade this is quite
good
oh yeah I love these credibly little
lines here I'm definitely getting dino
egg vibes off of this like Jurassic Park
oh yeah I'm like having a wave of
memories come across me right now at
school with all the kids being like
what's in your lunchbox I'm like I don't
know how to describe this to you but uh
it's a tea egg
it smells not that great but it's
amazing look at that cross-section yeah
there's like a gradient here you don't
see the flavors as they penetrate slowly
today I wish I could buy 12 of these at
the grocery store I want to live in this
egg this egg is perfection per baguette
Shawna little melt it I don't know why I
thought you're gonna say it but her
packed in like a doughnut you got like
three words one egg go excited
exceptional yummy place do you know
let's do it
well I am is with me Adam Oh huh he's
having enough eggs
he tells just by looking at him what did
that mean I really enjoyed that egg I
read that in Taiwan you can just get
those at 7-eleven I want that in America
it is time for hey give it to me I'm
ready for a hard-boiled egg fell I'm
excited to hear this egg bag
you know that dog egg let me see my back
dr. Seuss when he made green eggs and
ham it was actually a bet that he could
make a book under 50 words really who is
the idiot who didn't think dr. Seuss
could do that so we're on our way now to
Connie and Ted's here in West Hollywood
and they're gonna be serving us the
peekytoe crab and lobster omelet
peekytoe that is I was just imagining us
you know they'll shoot and you got a
stinky toe sticking out that's what I
was expecting
that expecting ah welcome to Connie and
Ted's my name is Sam Baxter I'm an
executive chef here kind of like a New
England style seafood house today we're
preparing one of our brunch dishes he
could tow crab and Maine lobster omelet
what is peekytoe it's a crab it's
actually a bycatch from the Maine
lobster Minh flavor is kind of similar
to Dungeness crab
so it's an omelet that has the thing
that you primarily catch the lobster and
sort of the byproduct all in the same
day one little egg bundle they're
hand-picked
shipped directly from Maine to our
doorstep here the first thing we start
with is cooking lobster about seven
minutes for a pound and a half I sit
down in the salted ice bath which helps
kind of retain the flavor take it out of
the shell once meat is out we warm it up
and a little bit of salted butter and
then add your shellfish in and pull it
back off the heat and then the time it
takes to make the omelet your crab and
lobster will be heated through just
right and the restaurant here we use a
hand mixer incorporates a little bit of
air we'll add the eggs in there give the
pan a good shape with spoon our crab and
lobster in there roll it up and then we
have our lemon beurre blanc that's on
the side mix that with little bit of
chive chervil and tarragon smoothing
that over the top garnish with a little
bit of chervil and kind of hard to beat
I'm having a mimosa because Sam
recommended it he's the best and I'm
driving so out from water you have a
taste
I like that smell that you get when you
drink it Cheers
[Music]
I'm gonna cut mine cuz I'm not an animal
like you look vomits are soft enough
that all you need is a fork oh alright
ready
[Music]
Wow I have one word describe homilies
ready for this pillow - heaven this
balance of flavors is really truly one
of the best we've had on this show all
the levels of taste that you want you
know the bright notes and the deep notes
but there's multiple representations in
each it's all just a symphony for your
mouth perfectly said we can all agree
that Adam is the egg of this dish he's
just that damn sack holding everything
together
you're the lobster in the crab and I'm
the beurre blanc everything that makes
coming back for a second bite I just
want to finish this omelette yeah give
some to Adam I get one more bite okay I
get one more bite one bite I know it's
not one bite here Adam I want one less
he's sick
all right let's go okay let's go
best bite of the day t Quito
you know peaky autocorrect of perking on
my phone is that the iPhones decision or
is that based on your usage of the word
perky so what do you think about the
omelet that might be the best element
I've ever had all the ingredients were
in perfect harmony
you know harmony in Korean harmony is
grandma yeah that's all my heart Monet's
all right you ready for an overeasy egg
fact let's meet with you yoga the older
and egg is the better it floats because
air gradually gathers within the shell
as in egg ages kind of a dead body
okay season two has been the season of
gold and caviar but we're going
throwback today we're going back the
truffle baby oh my god
[Music]
I'm Josiah Citrin the chef and owner of
Malisse restaurant in Santa Monica a
Malisse restaurant it's a contemporary
American restaurant was French
influences today I'm going to be
preparing a truffled egg dish I was
inspired by a style dish had in France
the flavor just matched perfectly
together the egg really absorbs the
flavor of the truffle yeah certainly
should be did you know is gonna go into
it you know crack it open the yolk is
gonna run out and they have brioche to
stop it all up we you the farm-fresh egg
from a biodynamic farm in Simi Valley
what's the difference from your ardent
variety a grocery store egg to this I
just think it's based on the diet the
chicken as they move it around the farm
all day so the egg is being seasoned
inside the chicken inside the chicken so
the first thing I'll do is I'll crack
the two eggs separate the yolk from the
white
you know season the white I'll whip it
put the whites in the mold indentation a
dimple to put the egg yolk in put a
little truffle oil little sea salt
little black pepper cover that what's
the rest of the egg whites you know I'll
just pop it in the oven for seven
minutes and while that's in the oven
I'll be reducing some chicken stock
truffle juice mushroom stock and then
I'll finish it with butter chives
parsley shallots Dutch lemon that'll be
the sauce and then while the other sauce
which is truffle juice brown butter and
cream it'll be a frost a foaming sauce
how many truffle eggs do you sell in a
week or in a day 20 to 40 a week people
love this people love it it's very
popular dish
[Music]
can I just say this is the dream being
showered with truffle sure that's the
dream yeah for me at least I love
truffle I don't like what this shows
done to you I can't believe though that
we've really gotten to this point where
this is like almost normal fluffy white
perfect egg it smells so strong you got
to be really careful you know when
you're in chemistry lab and you waft you
don't want a chloroform yourself you
know Stephen actually used to be a
chemist chemical engineer and I think
that is the most interesting thing about
what - Oh buddy I'm monitoring your
truffle it take do not hog
very surprising that is the best way to
eat truffle and check this out we've got
the cutest piece of toast in the world
here like Johnny Bravo toast and eggs
toast egg you gotta get truffle in there
here you know when you make a half-court
shot and you just have that immense
feeling of joy looks like there's a very
flavorful yo this is not your common
chicken that the co came from mmm me and
you we're to lay eggs things that I
would lay would be way tastier why is
that cuz I'm like a fatted calf you just
eat I'm not working out but that's not
how the most delicious meats are made
the most delicious meats are from
animals that move around so that the fat
can integrate with the muscle that's why
I would be more delicious than you how
can you rock-climb
I do many physical activities many
eyeball Steven ball hard
Steven stock on the day probably the
happiest I've been in an episode of were
that ever I just love eggs truffle has
like the ability to spread it through a
room like a fart well it's the best fart
I've ever spelled and boy have I smelled
some farts
[Music]
Wow
yeah flashback season one when I took
you on five truffle adventures I think
that truffle egg was my favorite truffle
thing I've ever eaten which egg was the
most worth it and it's given price point
honestly this is the closest it's
personally ever been for me and a worth
it episode Connie and Ted's was a really
great omelet that might be one of the
best lobster deals in Los Angeles but I
think that edge for me goes to loud
I kind of style myself as an old man
kind of curmudgeon eating a whole
hard-boiled egg that's been sitting in
tea and spices for 12 hours really just
speaks to my personality truffle egg
everybody knows I love truffle it's
pungent in the most delightful way but I
gotta say Connie and Ted's is buying
worth the winner it was like biting into
a heavenly plout of egg Adam what was
your most worth it oh and that's a wrap
on eggs
you're watching Always Sunny in
Philadelphia it's a character named Gail
the snail that goes with me yeah I have
a lot of saliva not my fault that when I
see food that lands in my mouth are
activated oh oh yes